hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we are back on monster on a world
again and today we're gonna be talking
about how to defeat arctan bird cool to
Roth so as always like the be if you do
enjoy subscriber for new I cover the
solo guides of all the monsters a
monster on the world and especially the
ones coming up in the new ice borne DLC
later next year so let's get started
with today's video so I do want to
clarify one thing I will not be talking
about things that she has already had
I've already done it got on Costa Roth
before when she first released include
the I in the top right that should be
popping up right about now or you can go
at the end of the video there will be a
link to that video if you want to see
all the stuff about her and not just our
tempered specific stuff but with our
temper to comes a few different changes
nothing too crazy but in the first phase
when you're going around shooting
cannons at her trying to at least get
her to the second face you can actually
fight her while she fights you her first
phase now has a new theme nothing too
crazy she just looks like a little bit
of a more metallic a lot of silver stuff
it looks really nice I really do like
what they did with the ark tempered
version of her though in Phase two
nothing else has really changed or in
the fact that the vertical fire attack
can now be chained twice so when she
goes down squats and does the fire
attack that goes completely straight she
will do a second one right after that
it's usually right next to where you
would be standing so if you're standing
right in front of her dodged the attack
and then right where you're standing
after that she'll do another one it's
honestly you could just keep running in
a sideways direction you dodged it super
easily not that too hard of a move phase
three is also gonna be very similar to
Phase two nothing really changed there
except to the fact that she does have
the vertical fire attack
so basically phase three is very similar
to Phase two and then in phase four when
she has the coat off of her the tail
swipe is actually a little bit slower I
don't know what the reasoning for this
was but I'm completely okay with that
the tail really didn't do too much
damage but she is arc attempt 'red it
will do a lot more damage now but like I
said phase 4 the tail swipe is gonna be
just a little bit slower and then on top
of that we have the new fury state which
is really cool now I've only had this
trigger one time in game so I'm not
entirely sure if this is all correct or
if I'm missing a few things so any one
of the comments below can definitely
correct me on this so definitely look in
the comments just in case but from what
I've seen there is a few multiple new
attacks besides the fact that she has a
completely new theme she's a lot more
faster and more aggressive than her
regular modes because she
the one with the Cohen throne without
the coat and now this period state so
it's even more aggressive than without
her coat on so watch out for those a lot
of faster attacks she has a ground pound
attack which I'll be showing on the
screen very slow but very high damaging
I believe it knocked out one of my
teammates in one hit so definitely be
aware with that obviously because she's
our temperatures gonna be doing a lot
more damage and then the last one is a
horizontal sweeping fire breath
that will cover most of the area now
don't be alarmed you can run away from
this if you're pretty far away it
doesn't reach across the entire map of
the area that you're in and as well
there is no backlash from the fire so
you actually can stand behind her while
she does this move and get in some free
hits maybe break the tail for some extra
pursue points stuff like that so really
not really a too hard of a move to dodge
but still a really cool move nonetheless
yeah guys that's gonna be the end of it
hope you guys do enjoy you guys for
coming out to the video like I said
nothing really too crazy with arc
tempered cool to Roth this isn't a huge
change as there would be like with Baja
soccer extreme behemoths or something
like that but still decent changes
switches up the gameplay a little bit
but I still found her pretty easy to
beat I ran it with a few solo queue
people got it in three or four times of
attempts so it really wasn't that hard
just normal cool to Roth strats get the
pursuit level up high enough on the
first run and then clapper on the second
run shouldn't be too hard you will be
getting some rainbow weapons I don't
know what these specific skills that
come with it
but I do notice that there is critical
status if you have a paralysis poison
type weapon and there's also a critical
element which will come with fire ice
water all that type of [ __ ] so if you
have any of those who are most likely
beginning those skills which boosts up
that even higher when you land critical
hits which is a really cool skill as
always if there was something that I
missed definitely leave it in the
comments below so everyone else can be
caught up to date and then with that
like to be Finn do enjoy subscribe if
you're new like I said in the beginning
I covered the solo guides of most of the
monsters a monster underworld and I plan
on doing a lot more with the new arc
tempered America gods a coming soon and
any new monsters that come out in
between here and ice-born which I'll
gladly be excited to cover as a guide so
definitely keep on the channel for that
and with that guys my two most recent
videos would be on-screen if you guys do
want to check that out that guys hope
ever here is today thank you for
watching the video enjoy arc tempered
cool to Roth let me know weapons you got
from her and peace out
[Music]